dis moi honnêtement ce fait comment tu
entends pas créer une meuf a été serré
y'a pas longtemps j'ai encore faim pour
malades aqf alors parle pas et qu elle
se plaît sur takieddine meuf de malades
mais par contre n'a pas filmé t'as pas
fait de fautes tu veux qu'on te croit
tous les trois on est ici à melun dans
le 7 sept
ça fait quinze piges contraire sont bien
jolies quotidien le petit c'est momo il
écarte ken une équipe de foot c'est de
10 ou des nôtres et leur entraîneur moi
je m'appelle moustène et mon kif et les
animaux [ __ ] c'est quoi ce truc de
raymond barre alors des fois je t'ai
soir agressivité sur morges peut pas le
faire il faut trancher
mon album j'ai très bien que je pétais
dans la muse le grand c abdelkrim et il
anime des soirées karaoké tout pour
manger
[Applaudissements]
et nouba on s'entend bien avec tout le
monde au quartier ma mi temps mais avec
fils de [ __ ]
en fait je tirais pas trop mal si ce
n'est pas ce connard de warner warner
tout le monde le déteste dans le
quartier et qui se prend pour une future
star du rap ou petits de rap conscient
maintenant que monsieur choses-là
tatoosh agent vous en avez pas marre de
rien faire de vos vies jamais tu avais
jamais une patte de meuf témoin
l'annnonce de couperin et ghazi bien au
fait j'ai joué dans le film
non non non c'est un peu comment ça
fonctionne la saison débute toi comment
tu pourrais dire
et c'est comme ça que toute cette
histoire de ou fall a commencé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sa mort tu parles comme ça
et c'est ok
est ce que mes lectures la prison ce que
je vais aller en prison un jour une
chambre